bonsoir mandar on est ravis de votre
représentation
pour arriver dans le taxi il faut que je
prenne la moto taxi avec le casque les
cheveux tout un plat tout ça je suis
coiffé comme un sou de bras là parce que
c'est une expérience mais je voulais
tellement vous voir ce sont désormais
deux banderoles avec un smiley clin
d'oeil qui ont été déployés hier sur
l'hôtel de ville plus subtile mais
toujours un soutien implicite au
mouvement est-ce qu'on s'en fout ou pas
Morad j'aime bien distinguer taxis parce
que ils déteste Hidalgo tousser et alors
on discute pendant
les Jeux Olympiques ça va être terrible
Paris va être bloqué ils sont très très
pessimistes mais trouver juste que un
Hidalgo a réussi à comprendre qu'elle
représente une entité morale qui est la
ville de Paris et que ce que Anne
Hidalgo pense la ville de Paris s'en
fout ces deux choses différentes donc ça
n'a pas de sens de faire des choses qui
n'ont pas de sens
de faire des choses qui n'ont pas de
sens Anne Hidalgo si juin 2023 ça tombe
bien on est en jour de manifestation
aujourd'hui pour les retraites voilà
ouais MSA au balcon il veut sa retraite
MSA au balcon 14e journée de
mobilisation contre la réforme des
retraites à l'appel de l'intersyndical
peu de perturbations dans les transports
mais 250 cortèges prévus aujourd'hui on
ne peut plus manifester c'est interdit
on n'a pas le droit de taper des
casseroles c'est interdit on n'a pas le
droit de déposer des amendements c'est
interdit d'imposer une réforme toute
seule ça s'appelle pas une république ça
s'appelle une monarchie présidentielle
et oui je pose la question de savoir si
on est encore en démocratie sanctionné
pour avoir chanté la Ferrera et concerne
un salarié de chant près de Maubeuge qui
travaille comme magasinier au rayon
boisson il a été mis à pied une journée
pour avoir chanté trop fort donc dans
les allées des 5 heures du matin il y a
une dérive il libérale qui est pas saine
du tout la manière de se comporter de
Monsieur Macron est infiniment plus
proche de celle de Monsieur Orban que de
n'importe qui d'autre en Europe
c'est-à-dire de pouvoir qui sont des
pouvoirs autoritaires décision qui a
provoqué la réaction de la CFDT de la
CGT qui ont appelé ce matin un
rassemblement de soutien en chantant
regardez
le coût du traitement des déchets en
France Laurent le couple
c'est 20 milliards d'euros par an voilà
si tu si tu faisais correctement les
choses avec tes déchets peut-être qu'on
travaille pas 64 ans vous faire des
économies mais bon
[Musique]
la question c'est est-ce que vous avez
consommé position
vous en avez dans la voiture ou pas
est-ce que vous allez dans la voiture
des stupéfiants j'aimerais pas savoir ce
qu'il y a dedans là Thomas il est en
mode mentaliste
une équipe formidable nous vous
attendons
juste est-ce que vous avez est-ce que
vous avez des produits studiants est-ce
que c'est des stupéfiants d'alcool
est-ce que vous êtes du cannabis de la
cocaïne dans votre voiture non
est-ce que vous vous interdisez des
aliments
j'en prends jamais et le chocolat
[Applaudissements]
mais vous avez un autre point commun
aussi c'est de d'avoir des hordes de
haine à chaque fois que vous sortez
quelque chose oui mais comment est-ce
qu'on gère ça en fait moi je prends ça
pour
comme je l'avoue c'est à dire que dans
cette démarche
[Rires]
il prend très très cher
un succès énorme que Nicoletta star de
la chanson des années 60 et 70 peine
pourtant à comprendre pour moi ce n'est
pas de la musique c'est de la vulgarité
c'est un produit
aberrants l'interprète de Mamie Blue qui
reproche à Aya Nakamura son comportement
et ses polémique critique aussi son
style musical elle ne chante pas bien
elle remue ses fesses elle frôle son
sexe sans arrêt ce n'est pas bien parce
que c'est des mômes qui viennent
l'écouter en France il y a un mépris
pour elle parce que parce que c'est une
femme parce qu'elle est noire parce que
elle a pas les codes de certains trucs
non en fait c'est elle extraordinaire
cette fille elle est très originale elle
est féministe elle est libre elle est
sexy elle envoie chez tout le monde elle
a de l'humour moi j'ai vraiment je la
trouve elle est très intelligente en
plus donc voilà ça m'énerve quand les
gens il y a une espèce de mépris oh
j'aime ça mais
mais ferme ta gueule beaucoup plus
intéressante que plein de chanteuses
devant tequelles tout le monde se
prosterne alors Nicoletta a-t-elle été
trop loin regardez cette couverture
partout là cette couverture du magazine
féminin anglais glamour Yuk sur cette
couverture c'est un homme ensemble voilà
il s'appelle Logan Brown c'est un homme
trans de 27 ans et quand je dis que
c'est une couverture historique et bah
c'est parce que c'est la première fois
qu'un homme trans ensemble et en une
d'un magazine Ok continue comme ça
ressemble bien couché
[Rires]
on voit la tête
je vois la botte
c'est compliqué
deux semaines après avoir posé pour
cette une c'était à la mi-mai alors ça
n'a pas été un accouchement simple
disons il y a eu pas mal de
complications il a accouché par
césarienne mais maintenant tout va bien
il est papa d'une petite fille qui
s'appelle Nova et vient de sortir un
livre pour parler de son expérience son
expérience de grossesse donc en tant
qu'homme
il y a toujours un papa une maman au
départ non ah bah oui mais attention les
amis
on va maintenant à Roland-Garros le
tournoi qui permet à Clément de se dire
alors c'est ça le bruit d'une femme qui
j'ai mis la
venez débattre avec Estelle passez une
bonne journée tu veux mon zizi et à
demain
[Musique]